montigny vous la zone
rien
tous les essais et tests de ce premier
remède on était mené et son efficacité
dans la réduction de l'éliminer
l'élimination des symptômes a été
prouvée pour le traitement des patients
atteints du convive 19 à madagascar
le
[Musique]
1 0
ah ah
hu
[Musique]
il a dit que nous allons ma panoplie
azaña est une amanite à narbonne à sa
résidence
en tout cas nature et au réformisme
cession de rambo saint bar avec sa
fondation mozilla
cya
ils les familles nos favoris sur la
dignité autant à la salle à présent à
madrid
on écoute les maritimes soutenu fammoni
manhattan autour de tête de tous à la
salle abus
dans mon temps
[Musique]
il
la position que luan et encourage toutes
les initiatives de recherche dans le
cadre du convive 19 mai ce qu'on
recommande de ce que tous ces c est cela
se fasse selon des protocoles
scientifiques et donc on ne peut pas
d'emblée dit que voici un médicament qui
est efficace même si il y à dépasser
peut-être historique traditionnelle
barre de semilly commun à construire
quelque chose il faut absolument mettre
en place et un protocole de recherche
peut être qu'ils ont identifié quelque
chose de prometteur mais il n'ya pas
encore d'évidence qui puisse nous
permettre de le proposer ou de le
connaître en tant que tel
[Musique]